[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans sa ou
caddie notre invité ce matin nathalie
matelly bonjour bon show merci d'être là
vous êtes directrice de canopée en
martinique le réseau de création et
d'accompagnement pédagogique ainsi que
coordinatrice du clemi alors le clemi
c'est cet organisme qui organise chaque
année d'ailleurs la semaine de la presse
à l'école
rappelez-nous d'ailleurs la
signification de cet acronyme alors le
clemi c'est le centre pour l'éducation
aux médias et à l'information
effectivement le clemi pilotes la
semaine de la presse et des médias à
l'école qui est un peu notre événement
phare mais pas que puisque le clemi
aussi dans le cadre de ses missions
assure la formation de l'ensemble des
enseignants du premier et du second
degré dans le domaine de l'éducation des
médias et de l'information
nous sommes également un éditeur de
ressources je vous a emmené un certain
nombre de ressources publié par le clemi
vous pourrez même lui montrer allez donc
éditeur de ressources et également nous
accompagnons le déploiement de deux
médias dans les écoles webradios wat tv
et voilà alors cette semaine de la
presse et des médias à l'école
est-ce qu'elle a encore son utilité en
2019 parce que bon c'est la 30e édition
au niveau national je sais pas si c'est
la 30e en martinique mais enfin voilà
quoi après plusieurs exercices
est ce que vous estimez que justement il
vaut encore cet exercice alors pour moi
ils votent c'est une utilité affirmé
d'année en année 1 30 ans voilà trente
plusieurs thématiques traitées ces
dernières années alors je vais vous
prendre un petit exemple hier c'était la
journée d'ouverture de lancement de la
semaine de la presse et des milliers à
l'école et nous avons eu
l'honneur d'accueillir les luminaires tv
ce sont des jeunes qui se lancent
justement dans la télévision et qui
disait mais voilà on se lance alors que
justement on se dit que ce sont des
médias qui sont de moins en moins
regardée par les jeunes et qui se donne
pour mission de renforcer et de
renforcer la chose mais de toute façon
au delà comme je vous ai dit de la
semaine de la presse l'élément phare
c'est ça c'est la lecture des médias la
compréhension du monde qui nous qui
hantent qui nous entoure et pour moi
c'est fondamental
nous sommes à l'ère des réseaux sociaux
le partage frénétique de l'information
et il me paraît important de former les
jeunes et les parents sur ces
problématiques et sur la manière de
traiter les infos qu'il reçoit via les
réseaux sociaux
alors je vous posais la question comme
ça un petit peu avec un ton de un peu de
poil à gratter
mais c'est vrai que cependant moi j'ai
l'impression que j'ai c'est que ça prend
et que d'année en année et peut-être
effectivement au cours des quatre cinq
dernières années de plus en plus
d'établissements de plus en plus
d'enseignants ou de deux conseillers
pédagogiques d'orientation enfin bref
tous ceux qui ont en charge
l'organisation de cette semaine de la
presse et des médias à l'école
eh bien ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à vouloir y participer c'est
tout à fait ça là on cette année nous
avons 80 16 établissements inscrits à
cet événement phare et je vous assure la
joie des enfants hier c'était assez
intéressant à voir parce qu'en fait nous
avons mis en place une salle de presse
où on avait une web radio installée dans
les élèves dans le cadre du lancement de
la semaine de la presse ont interviewé
le recteur qui étaient présents les
parrainent de la manifestation qui était
présent ou diam zebina et marie coll
csls en web radio et web télé et je vous
assure qu'ils ont pris leur rôle très au
sérieux il ya eu de nombreuses questions
je pense que ce sont
des métiers c'est un univers qui
passionne encore les jeunes qui
passionne les enfants vous avez pu le
voir aussi puisque vous avez accueilli
des classes à martinique première les
élèves sont toujours heureux de
découvrir l'envers l'envers du décor
alors on n'oublie pas que tout ça se
passe dans le cadre évidemment très
général de l'éducation nationale et
qu'il s'agit donc de former d'éduquer
les jeunes à savoir comment bien
s'informer et à l'heure de commandites
ont maintenant en français au clavier
qu'il faut dire un fox une contraction
de 1 fox et intox en bourse c'est
qu'après un fossé de l'info qui est
plutôt de l'intox et donc il s'agit
d'apprendre aussi aux jeunes à se méfier
de ça vous l'avez dit à l'heure du tout
internet des réseaux sociaux
voilà oui c'est votre mission est cassé
notre mission c'est une mission qui nous
a été confiée par le recteur de
l'académie de martinique monsieur pascal
jan donc il a missionné l'atelier
canopée martinique pour impulser les
actions autour de la semaine de la
presse et au taux de l'emi en
collaboration avec la responsable de
l'émission niveau du de l'éducation aux
médias d'information au niveau du
rectorat
et oui c'est extrêmement extrêmement
important puisque nous avons des élèves
qui baigne dans un univers tout
numérique
ben totalement on peut le dire parce que
déjà les parents ont tendance à sur
médiatisé en fait le moindre geste de
son enfant va le on va le poster sur le
réseaux sociaux tient il a fait ses
premiers pas et cetera extrait donc en
fait ils ne sont même pas encore arrivé
au stade de pouvoir utiliser ces outils
qui sont déjà dans le bain donc il ya
une vraie question à se poser sur
l'utilisation de ces données
et c'est en ça le clemi effectivement
intervient de manière très large puisque
en amont de la semaine de la presse et
des médias à l'école nous avons organisé
toute une session de formation autour de
ces de cette problématique notamment une
conférence à qui profite le big data
finalement c'est gratuit mais peut-être
tout simplement parce que le
consommateur est aussi peut être le
produit
et voilà donc sensibilisés
élève assez à l'utilisation que l'on va
faire des données qui les concernent
ouais alors ce sera aussi l'occasion
dites-vous de permettre à ces élèves et
aux enseignants qui sont avec eux de
pouvoir travailler aussi sur les limites
de l'information parce qu'on le rappelle
et on va y venir pour cette deuxième
partie d'émission que le thème cette
année c'est l'information sans
frontières mais mais avant tout la
formation a aussi ses limites
et voilà il s'agit tout en voulant
s'informer ou en voulant informer les
autres de ne pas se désarmer ou de
désinformer les autres alors on est
encore un peu dans la fox dans falbalas
ça va un peu plus loin ce que je veux
dire c'est que est-ce que ça parce qu'on
apprend à lire certains magazines ont ce
qu'on leur dit qu'il faut à la plusieurs
sources pour pouvoir être bien informé
voilà c'est exactement ça alors déjà de
voir comment une information peut être
traitée dans différents médias donc on a
un outil très intéressant pour ça et je
remercie notre partenaire se dit prêt ce
qui nous a permis de 2,2 qui nous a mis
à disposition une beaucoup de journaux
de magazines qui ont été donnés
gratuitement aux établissements
scolaires qui et les enseignants
documentaliste ont mis en place des
kiosques et l'intérêt aussi par exemple
pour une information donnée disons la
victoire des bleus de voir comment elle
peut être traitée dans différents médias
dans différents pays comment la même
info va être traité voilà dans
différents contextes donc le la
thématique l'information sans frontières
avec surtout de points d'interrogation
elle est intéressante parce que elle
permet finalement de réfléchir sur
plusieurs axes alors la notion de
frontière déjà quand on passe une
frontière mais effectivement on passe
avec son son passeport on est contrôlé à
la frontière qui contrôlent
l'information qui finalement pas de pays
en pays de téléphones portables en un
téléphone portable
c'est déjà une première question à se
poser pareil toujours cette notion de
frontière expliqué aussi que
l'information ne passe pas certaines
frontières dont parlait des pays où
finalement il n'y a pas la liberté de la
presse donc ça au tourisme vous voyez
plusieurs axes de réflexion et puis un
autre axe de réflexion sur cet aspect
finalement internationale
réfléchir un petit peu sur les choix et
et orio par exemple un média comme
martinique première et pourrait parler
ils reçoivent des informations qui
viennent du monde entier à un moment il
faut faire des choix
pourquoi on va choisir de parler de tel
ou tel pays donc en fait il ya tous les
aspects finalement géo politique
culturelle derrière le traitement de
l'information et c'est assez intéressant
à travers les kiosques à journaux de
voir les choix éditoriaux qui peuvent
être faits par un média par rapport à un
autre
nous sommes avec nathalie matelly dont
directrice de canopée coordinatrice du
clemi nous parlons dans 5 à 10 avec elle
donc de la semaine de la presse et des
médias à l'école on ne viennent
d'évoquer le thème de cette année cette
30e édition d'information sans
frontières est justement l'occasion
aussi de se pencher sur cette
mondialisation de l'information aussi
finalement avec la mondialisation
généralisée et précisément pour nos
élèves de la martinique qui certes font
partie de l'éducation nationale
française mais géographiquement sont
placés au centre de l'amérique dans les
caraïbes non loin de l'amérique centrale
l'amérique du sud et ses terres est ce
que c'est l'occasion aussi justement à
travers ce thème informations sans
frontières de leur dire que certes faut
pas se préoccuper ce qui se passe dans
le grand centre français à 8000 km mais
aussi tourné son regard le plus souvent
possible vers nos voisins de la caraïbe
vers l'amérique du sud l'amérique du
nord
bon voilà c'est alors là c'est vraiment
tout l'objet du projet de réseau canopée
réseau canopée c'est un opérateur public
un ministère de l'éducation nationale
les eaux canopée porte declémy et dans
dans le projet que je porte on a
vraiment un ancrage dans la caraïbe et
les projets portés par les réseaux
canopée ce viennent dans la dynamique
impulsée par le recteur et il ya deux
projets portés par le recteur d'académie
qui sont vraiment des projets
extrêmement intéressant donc il ya le
premier jeu reste 30 secondes parcourant
des anglais plus où on va justement
demandé aux élèves d'utiliser la web
radio pour pouvoir échanger avec leurs
voisins caribéens
moi je trouve ça intéressant et puis le
projet expression orale libre qui invite
les élèves justement à
avoir la capacité d'argumenter de faire
passer une information
voilà merci de vous couper un petit peu
notre de développement mais le temps qui
nous est imparti et dernier nathalie
matelly donc coordinatrice du clemi on
le rappelle l'organisme chargé de
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information merci d'être venu nous
parler de cette semaine deux de la
presse et des médias à l'école
bonne semaine merci je vous remercie et
j'avais toute la population à
s'intéresser à cette semaine à y
participer à venir chênois réseau
canopée on pense aux parents il ya un
guide de la famille tout écran donc je
le recommande à tous les parents voilà
bonne journée à vous tous merci
[Musique]